speaking of
other really powerful stories that you
were involved with is the aaron
hernandez trial
and the whole story the whole legal case
can you maybe
overview the big picture uh story and
legal case of aaron hernandez
yeah so aaron whom i missed a lot
um so he was charged with
a double murder in in in the case that i
tried
and this was a unique case in one of
those impossible cases
uh in part because aaron had already
been
uh convicted of a murder and so we had a
client who was
on trial for a double murder after
having already been convicted of
a separate murder and we had a jury pool
uh just about all of whom
knew that he had been convicted of of a
murder
because he was a very popular football
player in boston
uh which is a big football town with the
with the patriots
uh so you know so everyone knew that he
was a convicted murderer and here we are
uh defending for uh in a double murder
case
um so that was the that was the context
it was not case in the sense that the
this murder had gone
gone unsolved for a couple of years
and then a nightclub bouncer
uh said something to a cop who was
working at a club
uh that uh aaron hernandez was somehow
involved in that
in that murder that happened in the
theater district that's the district
where all the clubs are in boston and
where the
the homicide occurred and once
the police heard aaron hernandez's name
then
it was you know they went uh all out in
order to
to to do this they found a guy named
alexander bradley
uh who uh was a
a very significant uh
uh a drug dealer in the
uh sort of uh connecticut area
uh ver very significant very powerful
um and he essentially
in exchange for a deal uh
pointed to aaron said yeah i was with
aaron and
uh and aaron uh was the
uh was the murderer uh so that's how the
case came came to court
okay so that that's that's the context
what was your involvement in this case
like legally intellectually
psychologically
uh when this particular uh second
charge of murder so a friend uh called
me
jose baez uh who is the defense attorney
and he
uh comes to uh a class that i teach
every year at harvard the trial advocacy
workshop
uh as one of my teaching faculty members
it's a class where we teach students how
to try cases
so jose called me and
said hey i got a call
from massachusetts aaron hernandez uh
you want to go and and talk to him uh
with me
so i said sure so we went up to the to
the prison
and um uh and met
uh aaron and uh spoke with him for two
or three hours that first time
and before we left he said he he wanted
to uh retain us
uh he wanted to work with us and and
that started the representation what was
he like
uh what would in that time what was he
worn down
by the whole process was there still he
wasn't light in that
he was not he he had i mean more than
just the light he was luminous almost uh
he had a radiant million dollar smile
uh whenever you walked in uh my
first impression i distinctly remember
was
wow this is what a professional athlete
looks like i mean he walked in and he's
just
just bigger and more fit than you know
than
anyone you know anywhere and it's like
wow this
and you know when you saw him on
television he looked kind of little
and i was like so i just remember
thinking well what what do those other
guys look like
first said um and um
and he's extraordinarily polite uh
uh young uh uh
i was surprised by how young
he was both in mind and uh
and body but chronologically i was you
know thinking he was in his
you know in his early twenties i believe
uh but there seemed to be like an
innocent stone uh
in terms of just the way he saw the
world i think that's right they picked
that up from the
from the documentary just taking that in
i think that's right yeah
yeah uh so there is a netflix
documentary
titled killer inside the mind of aaron
hernandez
what are your thoughts on this
documentary i know if you've gotten a
chance to say i i did not i've not seen
it i did not participate in it i know i
was in it because of
uh there was news footage uh that but i
did not participate in it i had not
talked to aaron about uh
about uh press or anything uh before he
he died my strong view is that the
attorney-client privilege survives
death and so i was not inclined to talk
about anything that aaron and i talked
about
so i just didn't uh participate and and
and never watched not even watch huh do
you is that does that apply
to most of your work do you try to stay
away from
the way the press perceives stuff um
during
uh yes i try to stay away from it i will
view it afterwards
i just hadn't gotten around to watching
uh aaron because it's kind of it's kind
of sad
yeah so i just haven't watched it but i
definitely stay away from
the press during trial uh and
you know there are some lawyers who
watch it religiously to see what's going
on but
you know i'm i'm confident in my years
of training
and so forth that and that i can
uh actively sense what's going on in the
courtroom and
and that i i really don't need advice
from
joe 476 at gmail
uh you know some random guy on the
internet
telling me how to try cases so yeah it's
just to me it's just confusing and i
just i keep it out of my mind and
even if you think you can ignore it just
reading it will have a
a little bit of an effect on your mind i
think that's all i think that's right
over time i might accumulate
you